when this project started and Craig it
was my understanding that you thought
this was a twice told tale who wants to
know anything more about Tonya Harding
yes it's a these guys is a bit of a
prelude to this but when I got the call
about it was my agent on the phone and
he said hey I'm sending you this script
about Tonya Harding and literally in
that millisecond I went sir I've just
done two bioptics one sports biopic it
was so long ago and figure skating
wasn't something that I'd followed that
closely no thanks and they said and
manga Roberts attached to star and I was
like wow
that's such a crazy combination and I
love Magos walk and had followed it you
know through all the films she'd be
doing here in the states I hadn't seen
neighbors you're in Australia you run
into the same baby hey sorry about that
but just that dance that she can do
between the humor and the drama by still
staying in character and not letting the
comedy take away from the empathy for
the character I thought this could be
really interesting and then I read
Stephens script and it just blew me away
I hadn't read anything like it there's
you know 256 scenes and a hundred and
ten pages and it was so fast-paced and
the contradictory views and and the
highs and the lows and the drama and the
tragedy and I thought it would be
amazing for Margo and also Allison was
already attached so the same thing is
like that dance that she can do was that
tone and the humor you know I was
begging for it and Stephen I guess we
have your niece to thank for making you
watch a documentary about Nancy Kerrigan
and Tonya Harding yeah I was trying to
figure out what I wanted to write next
and I happen to see this great
documentary on 3430
that Nanette Burstein did called the
price of the price of gold and it was a
really crazy story but there were things
in it about class in America and the
disenfranchised and what we tell women
they're supposed to be and truth and the
perception of truth and it was all
framed in a whole lot of crazy
and it turns out that I feel really
comfortable there and so I went on the
Tonya Harding website to find out if the
life rights are even of a there's still
a Tonya Harding website there is a Tonya
Harding website I've been there and I
called the number for her agent and it
was a motel 6 I know and I just thought
there's I am so in doing this and I I
tracked down Tonya Harding and I tracked
down Jeff Gillooly it was a spec script
no one was paying me to do it and I just
kind of worm my way in and it got them
to agree to an interview and when I
interviewed them their stories were so
different and wildly contradictory that
I thought well that's the way to tell
the story I'll just put everybody's
point of view up there and let the
audience decide and Margo and Tom I
thought is it true you thought this was
made up you didn't think this was a real
thing you hadn't known about it yeah
when I read the script I thought it was
a complete work of fiction and yeah I'd
never heard of any of the names before I
was you know four years old at the time
when it happened and I was in Australia
I mean this this was a story that
reached Australia England and obviously
other parts of the world as well as
obviously being huge here but no I guess
I was yeah preoccupied at the time with
climbing trees or throwing rocks or
something I totally missed missed the
whole scandal but it was great because
then I could approach this story with no
preconceived notions and I didn't you
know feel a certain way about these
people or the events it was I perched it
with a clean slate and that was in the
end I think I think a better way of
approaching this so for someone coming
to this story especially titania for the
first time as a grownup who's not
acquainted with it before and who wasn't
steeped in kind of the tabloid tv-- of
the time what was your sense of her she
seemed a little like rebellious I liked
that she didn't fit in and I liked that
she was skating to ZZ Top instead
instead of like classical music and you
know she to me felt like the ultimate
underdog and I and I love I love gangsta
films I love you know I love the idea of
someone despite their circumstances
is reaching the top and and I felt like
when I was reading the script and
started researching that's what it felt
like here's this girl who would
literally skate onto the ice and have
commentators being like and here's a
girl coming from the wrong side of the
tracks and but like they didn't want her
there and and despite all that she's
there sewing her costume she's she's
doing all this and and she she makes it
I mean she has this triumphant moment
where she's the first u.s. woman to land
a triple axel in competition which was I
now understand is a huge athletic
achievement and then the tragedy of the
story of course is that it's completely
overshadowed by everything that came
next but but to me she did feel like an
underdog in some ways and I could get
behind that and Thomas a producer was
this a hard sell because you got the
Craig reaction which is well you know we
know this story what else can you tell
us about it
no I think you know when people ask why
making maybe about Tonya Harding like
there was an obvious reaction but like
Mark I said we got to come at it with no
prejudice no preconceived notions and we
just wanted to tell the story that was
on the script and and Steven managed to
write such a wildly entertaining story
and and we just got to bring these
characters to life and of course we went
down a rabbit hole of research and and
learned as much as we could but we still
came at it just from purely not wanting
to sympathize with Tanya or the Castro
as a villain which I think the media
obviously did and we got to bring that
to in you like Allison I gather the
Steven wrote this role specifically with
you in mind he's sitting next to you
nodding about this so and so I don't
remember too much about the mother did
that give you some latitude or was she
such a character that it was a it was
all about bringing her as she was to the
screen well I think Steven tried his
best to find the real levana and Tanya
did not know where her mother was and
nor if she were alive or dead and nor
did she care so every trail that he went
down to find her was was was left cold
and and so he created her from the
stories that he he got from Tanya and
Jeff and as a matter of fact
the one thing while they disagreed about
everything they agreed about who Levana
was that you know she was as horrible as
as we should we showed her to be as he
showed her to be was this a hard sell I
mean it was what eleven million dollars
in 31 days which sounds like a movie
title in itself pedal to the metal and
then you are selling something that
people thought we know too well so how
did that work for you you know Stevens
script did a lot of the work for us and
it was nice because it immediately
attracted obviously everybody on the
stage Margo
Craig Allison all came on board and it
just had a steam because of that the
challenge produce orally really is that
we wanted to protect the the story and
we wanted to do it in the right way and
not sand off its edges and so we were
working very much outside of this system
you end up backing into a number
oftentimes because of the foreign
pre-sales or whatever you're working on
that is it made it difficult
we had incredibly talented people
working for a sliver of their rates
because they they loved this project and
they loved the people on board and just
had that family atmosphere so we were
able to kind of navigate through a lot
of tough challenges the skating took up
a lot of time there were so many
different different looks and and and
and for from Margo and for all of our
cast and but we got through and it was
such a fulfilling process well so Margo
either that's the best CG I've ever seen
you you really did learn how to skate
that was on me really how did how did
you do because physically she's
different from you and yeah just the
demands of skating would do that yeah
how did you prep for that I mean I I did
months of months of training in the gym
and obviously on the ice I kind of lived
at the ice skating rinks pretty good
where the life really dresses the whole
time yeah no I mean not until we're on
set I did my exercise gear but it's it's
a it's a tough sport it's it's brutal
and I really didn't appreciate it until
I was actually doing it you know I
thought I can I can usually pick things
up kind of quickly but it took me two
months just to get on my outside edges
and after that things progressed quickly
but yes it was like five days a week
three four hours a day for four or five
months and it was also over Christmas it
was like day before my wedding at the
ice skating rink Christmas Eve at the
ice skating rink it was a lot of now
ironically that I'm not skating all the
time I actually really miss it but yeah
if despite all the training even if I
had 20 years to Train I'd never be able
to do never to be able to do a triple
axel and no could ice skate doubles
actually who were professional skaters
we they couldn't do a triple axel no one
could um yeah it turns out you know when
we approached our skate choreographer
Sarah Kelleher and said I know we just
need someone obviously you can double me
and they'll do the triple axel and she's
like no that's not possible six women in
the world have done it in the last 25
years and none of them can w and none of
them are in the country like well those
two in the country and they're both
Asian they couldn't double me so we're
like okay back to the drawing board and
thankfully Craig has worked a lot in the
commercial space and has a lot of close
relationships with VFX houses and things
like that so we were able to do the
triple axel with CGI and and all the big
really big jumps of face replacement and
then any of the skating dancing forward
crossovers back crossovers that's all me
you did break down that fourth wall I
mean in spite of the fact that it had
this documentary feel you still had
people like Alison speaking to camera I
mean not just to the interviewer but to
the audience in this why was that well
the interviews were in the script and
but this wasn't like any film script
that I'd read before because basically
it has the whole kitchen sink in there
which can seem like it's probably not
which was full of dirty dishes I made a
third it was but because we've got the
interviews and then they're there
they're contradictory interviews they're
not all telling the same story that
disagreeing amongst each other in the
scene they're talking to the audience
and then on top of that and then I said
I guys I want to introduce also breaking
the fourth wall in scenes and so we'd
pretty much put everything in there and
the fourth wall thing that came up was
basically talking about the violence and
how we
deal with the violence in this movie
beak and was one of the first questions
Mago asked me and and I said I think
it's gotta be brutal I think we've got
to show her life and which informs who
she was and the choices that she made
and how she sold the world and I've
always felt like when you'd see her in
these interviews you could see that
armor up and that defensiveness and that
defiance and you just the I think we
really needed to it would be a
disservice not to understand how she
grew up and what she lived with so it
was trying to figure out how to to do
that
finding Sebastian was a huge part of
that puzzle because it was trying to
figure out why they they would keep
going back to that cycle and exploring
it and then as we were working on it I
thought you know we'd watch interviews
with Tanja and she was so blase about it
and be like yeah my mom hit me about it
sake she just shrug it off and you felt
like that she was so disassociated from
and so immune to it they're like well
she breaks the fourth wall in these
scenes that are so atrocious it really
reinforces a state of mind that she can
just disassociate herself from it and
talk to us in the middle of this and so
intellectually I thought that would work
and actually as I shot the film just to
make it all the more complicated we shot
all those scenes breaking the fourth
wall and not breaking the fourth wall
and added in a lot of camera work so I
had really had a choice on how much of
the interviews we used I mean we could
have actually used nine of them the
amount of coverage we ended up doing so
in the Edit with Tanja we had that
really that luxury of deciding just how
much we go to those interviews or not at
all although and then we had all of that
to work with and post I want to thank
you all for this film